today we're breaking down halo
infinite's new maps and explaining why
kingdom hearts 4 sora looks so different
halo infinite season 2 lone wolves will
be here in just a few weeks and 343
industries has revealed the two new maps
spartans will be murdering each other on
named catalyst and breaker the maps are
very different from one another with one
focusing on cold industrial interiors
while the other is an open desert map
designed for big team battle for fans of
traditional arena style multiplayer you
can look forward to catalyst in a blog
post on halo waypoint multiplayer level
designer tyler entrue described it as a
tunnel-like map with 4runner structures
complete with the light bridge you've
come to know and love from halo it
shares some similarities with epitaph
from halo 3 and the ever popular haven
from halo 4 but with a scrappier feel
there is more banished influence as the
group relies heavily on captured
technology and weapons rather than its
own creations breaker is an open outdoor
map designed for big team battle
especially ctf matches with a base on
either side making for huge skirmishes
in the midsection huge pieces of wrecked
machinery are visible here building on
what you see throughout halo infinite's
campaign there's even a death pit that
you can jump in a warthog if you're
skilled enough but hitting the ramp
incorrectly will result in a very
unceremonious death halo infinite season
2 kicks off on may 3rd and also comes
with two new armor cores a new battle
pass and the modes land grab and king of
the hill and more story events switching
gears from chief to sora kingdom hearts
4 looks set to introduce a few graphical
changes to the long running series which
includes a more mature look for
protagonist sora and other updated
visual tweaks in a new interview with
famatsu that was translated by vgc
series creator tetsuya nomura spoke
about these changes and the world of
quadratum which serves as an afterlife
of sorts nomura said quote from sora's
perspective quadratum is an underworld a
fictional world that is different from
reality but from the point of view of
the inhabitants of the quadratum side
the world of quadratum is reality and
the world where sora and the others were
is the other side the fictional world
nomura added that goofy and donald duck
are searching for sora in kingdom hearts
4 and if he were to return to his
original reality he'd start to resemble
his more cartoonish design again as fans
have discovered quadratum has been
referenced before as an unreality
separate from the other realms in the
series with kingdom hearts 3 confirming
that location as part of a secret ending
kingdom hearts 4 is the start of a new
saga for sora and pals and while it'll
still be a while before the game
launches fans have begun scouring
footage for clues as to what they can
expect from the square enix and disney
collaboration some eagle eye fans claim
to have spotted a star wars tease in the
game's reveal trailer which isn't too
implausible given that disney owns the
sci-fi franchise but nomura isn't the
only series creator reacting to
something metal gear and death stranding
mastermind hideo kojima opened up about
sony acquisition rumors playstation
studios recently updated its first party
studios banner to include sam bridges
the protagonist of death stranding a
playstation console exclusive its
director's cup version was released on
both playstation consoles and pc kojima
posted the banner himself onto his
twitter account without providing any
further contacts fueling rumors that
sony may have acquired kojima
productions and that perhaps an official
announcement would be coming soon
however kojima retweeted his post and
apologized for the confusion he caused
he clarified quote i'm sorry for the
misunderstanding but kojima productions
has been and will continue to be an
independent studio kojima productions is
also working on a game with microsoft
amid these acquisition rumors kojima's
xbox project is reportedly still
progressing as planned let us know in
the comments if you're excited for
halo's new maps and we'll see you next
week
you